ah
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález haití se
mantiene en huelga general debido a la
falta de alimentos combustibles también
la crisis económica la pandemia la
inestabilidad política y sobre todo la
inseguridad las bandas delincuenciales
han ganado terreno y tienen a este país
caribeño ya su gobierno contra la pared
agravando aún más las ya difíciles
condiciones de los habitantes en el
siguiente reportaje realizado por la
redacción de france 24 los ponemos en
contexto sobre la situación que está
viviendo ese país veamos
así luce la economía de una ciudad
fantasma este martes las calles de
puerto príncipe se encontraban desiertas
es la segunda jornada de una huelga
general de tres días en la que los
haitianos protestan contra el
desabastecimiento de combustible
no hay gasolina disponible pero las
pandillas la están manipulando para
desestabilizarnos
éstas aumentan su poder y en una rueda
de prensa y michel y ser líder de la
federación de bandas g9 envió un mensaje
contundente no habrá combustible hasta
que dimita el primer ministro ariel
henrique
estamos pidiendo su renuncia no porque
tengamos un problema personal con nadie
de anrig sino porque su nombre está
involucrado en el asesinato del
presidente yo en el móvil común pac si
penas así en las visitas del juez
las pandillas están bloqueando tanto
carreteras como entradas a los depósitos
de gasolina de los puertos el galón que
costaba dos dólares está ahora en 20
dólares no hay transporte las empresas
están parando y 50 hospitales en el país
han tenido que cerrar
bompas otras instituciones pueden cerrar
sus puertas pero los hospitales no
pueden quedarse sin combustible estamos
en la situación más crítica este es el
límite
desabastecimiento secuestros e
inseguridad que se suman al terremoto
del 14 de agosto y al magnicidio del
presidente lleven el mois el 7 de julio
el espiral de crisis la necesidad la
violencia e incertidumbre parecen estar
seguidos a este país sobre todo después
del asesinato del presidente jouvenel
moix el pasado 7 de julio que
desestabilizó a este país políticamente
como ya lo veíamos también seguido de un
terremoto que dejó miles de muertos y
ahora la inseguridad y los crímenes por
parte de diferentes pandillas que están
sembrando el terror entre la población
qué hacer con haití cuál es la salida a
estos múltiples frentes de crisis que
tiene esta nación caribeña
estamos ante una bomba de tiempo una
bomba que pueda estallar en el tiempo
cercano la situación en haití es nuestro
tema de debate hoy en france 24 y para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
sabina manigat ella es socióloga
politólogo e investigadora de la
universidad quisqueya de haití ella se
encuentra en la ciudad de puerto
príncipe la capital haitiana también se
encuentra con nosotros el doctor luís
jean pierre lo visto él es doctor en
ciencia política y administración
pública él se encuentra en la ciudad de
barcelona
y aquí en el estudio de france 24 nos
acompaña manuel camilo gonzález él es
politólogo e internacionalista
experto en temas de américa latina y
también en partidos políticos e historia
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en el debate a través
de sus comentarios y sus preguntas en
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
síganos como arroba france24 bajo ese y
arroba sant y luego les recuerdo que
nuestra etiqueta es numeral del debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios
participen en este debate sobre este
país caribeño y su situación comienzo
entonces con sabina y en la capital
haitiana la ciudad de puerto príncipe
saben gracias por acompañarnos en el
programa y en qué momento las pandillas
cobraron tanta fuerza y pusieron en
jaque a este país caribeño
bueno muchas gracias por la invitación
gracias a los televidentes y a los
panelistas que nos acompañan
quisiera tal vez hacer un par de
comentarios acerca del papel que juegan
las pandillas en la actual crisis
política en el que es cierto que hay dos
elementos la huelga
la huelga convocada
para hacer frente a la escasez de gas de
combustible y el problema de la
inseguridad han parado al país varias
veces incluso desde hace unos cinco o
seis meses y no solamente esta semana
sin embargo yo creo que hay que poner en
contexto el problema de las pandillas en
primer lugar recordando que han sido
construidas han tomado fuerza a partir
de prácticas políticas que se remontan a
los años ochentas y que involucran no
solamente a los actuales gobernantes y a
los exparlamentarios sino también a
elementos del sector privado ha sido una
manera de de
de manejar la política en este país por
unos 25 ó 30 años el problema o la
agudeza que toma esa crisis hoy en día
está debida fundamentalmente a la falta
de legitimidad de todas las
instituciones que hasta el asesinato de
goya de luís podían pretender
algún tipo de legalidad sino de
legitimidad entonces hoy en día las las
pandillas no tienen no tienen amo porque
los sectores que los manejan ya no
tienen un ápice de legitimidad y ahí es
donde entra el problema de saber cómo se
va a restablecer esa legitimidad porque
legalidad es una cosa legitimidad otra
muy diferente y ahí el país la sociedad
haitiana tiene algo que decir al
respecto
doctor lo visto en la ciudad de
barcelona su opinión y su tal vez su
complemento a esta pregunta que hacía yo
sobre el momento en el que estas
pandillas han tomado tanta fuerza y han
puesto en jaque a esta nación caribeña
que piensa usted
yo creo eso es que estas pandillas y yo
voy un poquito más reciente que mi
hermana amiga yo un poquito más reciente
que se empieza sobre todo a partir de
los años 87 por una sencilla razón y
ella tiene razón de decir desde los años
80 pero a partir de mi noches
1986-87 y cuando se pierde yo no digo
que los duvalier estaban bien pero se
pierde un poquito de temor a la
autoridad
durante los regímenes de duvalier había
autoridad o sea alguien que iba a ser
algo la persona piensa más de una vez
antes de hacerlo después del gobierno de
duvalier con esta cosa que ya todo el
mundo empieza a tomar la calle y también
los valores institucionales se ha
perdido yo entiendo que no había derecho
no había democracia durante el gobierno
de lugar
pero había autoridad hoy en día no hay
ninguna autoridad en el país por ejemplo
un policía es como si fuera un dios por
ejemplo yo he escuchado comentario donde
un policía sale con un oficial de punto
ministro y el policía para darle eso de
seguridad a este ministro el ministro le
debe algo adicional al pago que recibe
este policía ahí empieza el problema de
estacionalidad y lo otro también las
pandillas tienen mejores condiciones que
las mismas fuerzas públicas es algo que
tenemos de atacar si no hacemos esto las
instituciones se van allí no se va a
poder hacer nada pasó acá al estudio de
france 24 para preguntarle a manuel
camilo gonzález nuestro invitado sobre
este fenómeno de las pandillas que
veíamos algo habitual en países como
colombia o tal vez en países como
centroamérica y según lo que nos
explican nuestros invitados este
fenómeno en haití ya existía desde hace
muchas décadas pero toma visibilidad en
los últimos días a raíz de los hechos
recientes las plantillas un fenómeno que
tal vez estamos pasando por alto en
américa latina es un problema social
bueno es un problema social en la medida
de que los países de américa latina son
muy desiguales en ese sentido el reparto
de la riqueza y los ingresos que tienen
la población pues incentiva y gracias a
la ilegalidad hacia las economías
ilícitas yo digamos que estoy de acuerdo
con los panelistas que nos acompañan hoy
diciendo que hay un antecedente que es
claro que en haití a partir de los
regímenes de los duvalier pues una
deconstrucción del estado de decir no
hubo un asentamiento en fuerzas del
orden de la seguridad como el ejército
como la policía sino que los duvalier se
valieron un poco de grupos paramilitares
esos grupos paramilitares cuando cae el
régimen de duvalier pues empiezan a
buscar una nueva una nueva
reconfiguración una nueva organización y
toda mucha más fuerza con los regímenes
democráticos es decir post 1990 y sobre
todo con la invasión que sea en el 94 y
eso tiene alguna forma un efecto en como
los vemos los haitianos y sobre todo
estas bandas criminales empiezan a
contestar el estado es decir de alguna
forma las pandillas se han posicionado
como un actor clave para movilizar votos
pero también para presionar a los
gobiernos para generar una serie digamos
de cambios pero unos cambios que
solamente favorecen a estas
organizaciones y no realmente a los
ciudadanos además a la población que la
que está en medio de este de esta
disputa entre el estado y estas
pandillas el doctor lo visto usted
mencionaba que las pandillas están mejor
equipadas y en mejores condiciones que
la misma policía haitiana quien financia
estas pandillas hay financiamiento
internacional de donde vienen los
recursos para que estas pandillas
accedan a mejores armas ya mejor
equipamiento
muy bien
normalmente supuestamente a un élite
nate supuestamente a un élite económico
hay un élite político normalmente estas
pandillas están al servicio de este
élite por ejemplo si uno mira bien las
pandillas donde actúan actúan telas en
los los barrios populares o sea ellos
nunca van a actuar en los barrios donde
viven los ricos no han hecho cosas que
puedo decir que los ricos no pueden no
pueden bajar a sus negocios cuando los
negocios de los ricos de la clase
supuestamente elite donde están estos
negocios están más o menos en la
cercanía donde vive la gente normal la
población y estas personas no le han
pasado nada o no pregunta hay sospecha
porque esas personas que tienen tanto
dinero y no les ha pasado nada nunca se
les ha tocado como le ha dejado el
pueblo del llano
y xavi en su opinión al respecto y sobre
estos intereses que pueda haber por
parte de los políticos por parte del
empresariado por parte de la clase alta
haitiana ellos son los que financian
estos grupos de estas pandillas para tal
vez para su propia protección como lo ve
usted
bueno evidentemente de una relación
entre el poder político
las pandillas
y el financiamiento del tráfico de armas
y de municiones que hoy en día está
poniendo en jaque la seguridad de la
población
e
lo recordaba el señor lo visto y también
el el compañero colombiano que ayuna hay
una relación directa entre el sector
privado y el financiamiento de las
pandillas
esto que lo pongan antes o un poco
después de la salida de los rivales
realmente tiene menos que ver con el
poder que con esos héctor esos sectores
de la burguesía de la oligarquía que
siempre se han protegido
pagando a ciudadanos que viven en los
barrios populares para asegurar sus
propios negocios entonces de ahí viene
lo esencial ahora hay un tráfico
internacional ahí es donde viene la
parte regional que mencionaba en el
colega
colombiano
hay un hay un aspecto internacional en
el desarrollo de las pandillas que tiene
que ver con cierto
cierto cambio en la manera de ver la
gobernabilidad de los países cuando
vienen de los países del tercer mundo o
del sur hay una relación directa entre
el tráfico de armas que se desarrolla el
desarrollo de las pandillas y el
debilitamiento de los estados está bien
pero esto no no va en contravía con lo
que dijo uno de los líderes de estas
pandillas que dijo que haití necesita
que sea el 5% de la gente que controle
el 85 por ciento de las riquezas del
país que no sea así que este no sea el
escenario refiriéndose precisamente a
esta pequeña clase empresarial y élite
haitiana que controla diferentes
sectores allí esto entonces no va en
contra a esta afirmación que dieron en
medios y en redes con esta afirmación de
que ellos son los que lo financia en
estos estos empresarios
bueno estas pandillas
hablan el lenguaje que se les pide y que
está de moda o sea si mi sevilla que es
un
criminal patentado y que tiene que no no
no no
no hace falta presentarle como uno de
los peores obstáculos hoy en día para
que hay algo de inseguridad en el país
es el primero que dice que limita el
gobierno y nosotros nos vamos a casa
cuando son responsables por la mayoría
de los secuestros del
bloqueo de calles y de la imposibilidad
de abastecer el país
en la combustible porque están están
bloqueando las salidas principales desde
la capital hasta el resto del país la
yunga hay un lenguaje un discurso y
después está la realidad que es muy
diferente ese doctor lo visto le
pregunto por esa imagen que vimos a
través de medios de comunicación
internacionales y a través de las redes
sociales de uno de los líderes de estas
pandillas dando una rueda de prensa
dando declaraciones diciendo que no
tenían nada en contra del primer
ministro en rey pero que su reclamo era
que tenía que dejar el poder el hablando
a los medios de comunicación como si
fuera un actor político completamente
legítimo
buena pregunta eso no es el arroz eso no
es la primera vez que pasa
en toda la historia del país pero lo más
lo más triste de esta situación le voy a
decir lo más triste de esta situación
yo diría que él se presenta así porque
hay un vacío en el país hay un vacío en
este ritual la clase intelectual del
país se tuvo que salir del país o sea no
hay quien toma una agenda para o por lo
menos díaz a este pueblo o sea es lo que
hacen la oligarquía la oligarquía del
país tratar de
sacar a los que pueden vivir que pueden
guiar a la gente de michelle 17 es un
guante de pandillero lo entendemos pero
hay muchas personas es lo más triste
porque
en
eso un pandillero
[Música]
y es un pandillero que tiene un discurso
pero poco a poco se va ganando y va
calando dentro de el imaginario de la
gente manuel camilo le pregunto por esta
imagen también de este líder de una
pandilla en redes sociales y en los
medios de comunicación esto no deja en
jaque al estado haitiano como ya lo
decía el doctor hay un vacío no se
aprovecha este vacío como queda entonces
la institucionalidad ahí en ese
escenario haití podemos clasificarlo
como un estado fantasma es decir todos
de alguna forma compiten por una
autoridad que no está asentada en el
territorio las pandillas controlan más o
menos el 60 por ciento del territorio
son los que al final de cuentas suplen
la digamos la ausencia de ese estado
pues proveyendo sus servicios por
ejemplo lo del gas lo de la gasolina lo
el agua de los servicios públicos y esa
digamos suplantación del estado pues de
alguna forma uno lo puede también ver
desde una soberanía criminal es decir
hay una cohabitación casi que complacía
entre actores estatales y actores
criminales pero lo que vemos ahora con
lo de ser y ser de alguna forma con
amenaza frente al primer ministro es que
esta soberanía criminal está a punto de
romperse a favor de los criminales
porque al final de cuentas si ya no esa
cohabitación si no hay una imposición de
los criminales pues vamos a ver que ese
estado realmente ya no es un estado que
se está sentando en el territorio por
medio de los criminales sino que son los
criminales los que están buscando
aspirar a tomar totalmente el control
del poder político en haití yo no
reemplazaría el otro es algo en
escenario hay algún antecedente similar
en algún otro país tal vez de nuestra
región o tal vez en otro continente que
tenga un escenario similar de grupos
delincuenciales que empiecen a suplantar
al estado y llegan a reemplazarlo como
para ver ese caso pues digamos en la
historia pues ha visto que países como
el congo como libería como somalia
tuvieron experiencias cercanas a ser
estados fallidos pero no estados
fantasmas porque porque al final de
cuentas los actores y aquí hay un
paralelo con seres el tercer viene de la
legalidad es una ex policía
muchos digamos en somalia en liberia
pues también eran agentes del estado y
lograron legitimarse tanto como a las
estatales pero actores con legitimidad
lo que vemos en haití es que
prácticamente hay un desplazamiento
progresivo incluso que acelerado de las
autoridades estatales en favor de las
pandillas y sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta que el chile cero que ha hecho
desde 2020 es tratar de confluir de
hacer unir a una serie de pandillas que
contra el territorio con tal de asentar
su poder mucho más y de alguna forma
contestar ese poder que tiene digamos a
ariel henry como primer ministro
sabina allí en puerto príncipe ustedes
que están allí en el terreno en el día a
día estas pandillas tendrían tal vez de
trasfondo un interés político que piensa
usted
yo realmente
tengo una mirada tal vez diferente del
doctor camino
y lo visto también
no sé si porque estoy aquí en haití
pero yo le pondría algunas algunos
matices importantes no solamente al
poder real que tienen esas pandillas
sino también al hecho de que
sabemos sabemos por haber hecho la
experiencia no hace tanto tiempo
en algún lugar entre 2004 y 2006 7 de
que pandillas que supuestamente le
imponían a respirar a toda la población
una de las expresiones que se usaron en
el 2006 cuando había pandillas
secuestros lo mismo que ahora en 15 días
se acabó con el problema y se acabó con
el problema porque los amos de este
proceso reaccionar y aquí me quiero
referir
específicamente a los actores
internacionales externos que están
tolerando no que los hayan fábrica pero
tolerando y por lo tanto dándole espacio
a esas pandillas para que se pueden
jactar de tener algún poder
con eso no quiero decir que el problema
se pueda resolver en dos horas como
algún algún
parlamentario de estadounidense se
atrevió a decir sino que realmente
acabando con la cabeza y sobre todo con
otra voluntad que el sector privado
pueda que pueda manifestar si el
problema está todavía
es posible controlarlo yo no creo que el
país sea ni un estado fantasma ni que se
vaya a la el caos total bueno saben pero
hay opciones y ahí hay actores en ese
país que no se solicitan por alguna
razón sabin y con esos actores con esa
institucionalidad que usted dice que si
hay allí en haití como pueden entonces
hacer frente a esta situación allí
internamente sin tener que recurrir a
escenarios internacionales o ayuda
internacional y ya le hago la misma
pregunta al doctor lo visto
institucionalidad no hay hay un problema
de institucionalidad claro hace dos años
que el régimen práctica primero materia
y en los dos últimos años
en los menos hasta su asesinato se
empeñaron en destruir todas las
instituciones que pueden manifestar
alguna legalidad del estado entonces si
hay un problema de legalidad pero
también hay que plantear el problema en
términos de legitimidad y ahí tenemos a
un movimiento social pujante que se está
organizando que es que ha propuesto un
acuerdo político al actual gobierno
ilegítimo y que está debatiendo para ver
cómo lograr que los que dirijan al
actual gobierno ilegítimo le dan chance
a los haitianos de decidir por sí mismo
me estoy refiriendo al acuerdo del 30 de
agosto y yo creo que si no se toma eso
en cuenta entonces si la única opción es
que haya una intervención que por
supuesto del pueblo haitiano no quiere
claro no hoy es el destino de los
haitianos
tienen que decidir qué es lo que quieren
para su país le hago esa pregunta
entonces al doctor lo visto dentro de la
institucionalidad que hay con las
deficiencias o que no hay o que carece
según lo que nos explica sabin y el
escenario político que hay como puede
entonces el estado revertir esta
situación y ganar terreno frente a las
pandillas y esta situación por lo menos
para atacar un frente de la crisis
porque el país hace frente a múltiples
problemas en este momento
mira vamos a decir las cosas como son
muchas veces hay mitos los haitianos
tienen mitos desastres mil años que los
americanos tal cosa carlota por favor
el problema que tenemos un haití es un
problema haitiano que se puede resolver
allí mismo por qué porque en haití en la
historia de este país yo a decir una
cosa muy importante de pronto los
panelistas de punto se van a sorprender
en la historia de este país de lo que yo
estudié
solamente este país y en mi conocimiento
conoció dos jefe de estado
una cosa que es presidente otra cosa es
jefe de staff
yo diría de salir
yo no soy defendiendo alfonso a duvalier
yo diría por su área qué significa eso
cuando tú tienes jefe de estado hay
política hay es difusión es que hace
respetar bien sea por temor o lo que sea
ahora bien le va a decir una cosa qué
pasó
el primer ministro iba a un sitio el 17
si no estoy mal de octubre el mismo jefe
de demanda que se llama jimmy 6 y le
pidió al primer ministro de llegar a
este sitio y él si pudo llegar el jefe
de la pandilla pudo llegar a este sitio
donde murió de salir
y el primer ministro quiso ir y no pudo
ir entonces lo que yo estoy diciendo yo
creo que es un problema de que hay que
tener instituciones lo otro también lo
último que para terminar
el problema de las pandillas no se puede
resolver solamente en el campo de
batalla hay que resolver este problema
es un problema social hay que mirar cómo
vienen estas personas en los barrios
pobres hay que mirar las escuelas la
educación hay que fortalecer estas
problemas tú puede cantar las armas de
estas zonas hoy pero mañana vuelven las
armas porque habrá gente que quieren
aprovechar de ellos por falta de
educación por falta de un bote de
oportunidad esta gente vuelven con las
armas claro siempre va a ser la opción
más fácil retomar las armas manuel
camilo aquí en el estudio de france 24
ya ellos han explicado el tema de la
institucionalidad la fortaleza que puede
o no tener el estado interno para hacer
frente a esto es suficiente para
combatir este mal de pandillas
inseguridad falta de educación
infraestructura un gobierno es que es
prácticamente como una necesidad de
volver a empezar
efectivamente como es es volver a
empezar porque tristemente haití se
enfrenta a un proceso de reconstrucción
del estado
la historia varios digamos caudillos
varios ejércitos privados pues a lo que
han hecho es desmantelar el poder del
estado porque el poder del estado
significa concentrar ese poder
concentrar la autoridad en una
estructura y en un sistema legal y
legítimo que va en contra de sus
intereses entonces yo creo que hay tiro
que se enfrenta es básicamente un
proceso de volver a construir su estado
por eso digo que es un estado fantasma
es decir el estado está consagrado la
constitución pero en el territorio no
hay institución entonces lo primero que
tienen que hacer los haitianos los
actores políticos es construir
instituciones y esa es la construcción
de instituciones tiene que ir acompañado
por uno por el apoyo de la gente es
decir la legitimidad pero también es
necesario construir la legítima desde lo
internacional no digo yo que al final de
cuentas sean los atrayentes nacionales
que se apropien del proceso sino que
acompañen el proceso que sean al final
de cuentas unos actores que coloquen
líneas rojas a los actores que tratan de
contestar al estado para que el estado
pueda seguir su curso normal se puedan
formar lograr legitimidad de las de los
ciudadanos y al final de cuentas el tipo
elecciones porque a final de cuentas
estamos hablando de una situación
excepcional y por excepcional hablo que
es autoritaria tenemos un presidente
asesinado un primer ministro que ni
siquiera puede salir del palacio porque
lo quieren asesinar y unas pandillas que
al final de cuentas se están tratando de
contener al estado para que no digamos
afecte sus intereses ya hemos hablado
del estado hemos hablado de la
institucionalidad hemos hablado de estas
pandillas saben y usted mencionaba los
movimientos ciudadanos qué garantías hay
para los ciudadanos haitianos para estas
organizaciones que se están conformando
para para tratar de buscar una salida a
esta situación y sobre todo el pedido
más grande que hace unos haitianos y es
unas elecciones limpias transparentes y
prontas
pues precisamente de eso se trata se
trata efectivamente de volver a
construir un estado
que ha sido
totalmente
desmoronado por 10 años de un régimen
quiero
precisar un régimen neo duvalierista que
era un intento de recomponer los
elementos autoritarios y dictatoriales
del estado haitiano
entonces hay que reconstruir el estado
hay que hacerlo con el movimiento social
que está en haití yo no creo y no estoy
hablando en términos de idealismo yo no
creo porque eso se ha tratado tantas
veces de hacer que desde lo externo se
pueda decirlo en este país en este país
hay que estabilizar la minustah estuvo
ahí 17 años tratando de estabilizar este
país verla sin que se le pregunte a la
gente cómo quiere volver a llegar a
instituciones democráticas el país ha
pasado de elecciones con un
77 excepto hasta 80 por ciento de
participación en el no en las elecciones
de 1990 a menos de 20 por ciento de
participación en las últimas elecciones
eso es lo que hay que reconstruir si el
país quiere elecciones que la elección
es que queden que den fe de la
democracia que el país que quiere
construir no elecciones para mantener
las dos minas mismas los mismos
intereses de poder de la oligarquía en
el gobierno importante ese punto está
bien llegamos a la recta final del
programa el momento para las
conclusiones y lo que pueda suceder en
el tiempo cercano en el futuro cercano
en este país dado el escenario político
que ustedes han explicado doctor y lo
visto en la ciudad de barcelona su
conclusión qué va a pasar en este país
en las próximas semanas siempre lo digo
no tenemos la bola de cristal para
averiguar el futuro pero su percepción
hacia dónde se dirige su país haití
desafortunadamente ojalá que me equivoco
pero no veo nada bueno por una sencilla
razón los que quieren mantenerse en el
poder cada vez más cogen más poder y lo
hacen con más violencia la única el
único camino que yo vengo diciendo hace
muchos años a mis compatriotas el único
camino es la educación votar es en la
educación fortalecen las instituciones
pero en corto plazo más violencia ojalá
que me equivoco más violencia más
asesinatos
manuel camilo aquí en el estudio tejas
también para el cierre del programa
manuel camilo su conclusión sobre lo que
puede suceder en este país en términos
políticos sociales con este escenario
que hemos descrito bueno a corto plazo
lo que vamos a ver es un predominio de
las pandillas sobre todo del g9 que es
la pandilla o la confederación criminal
que tiene el isr en haití creo que eso
va a seguir de alguna forma siendo una
competencia para el estado haitiano y
como tal para el primer ministro
y eso digamos va a seguir digamos
dificultando que al final de cuentas
este sea un estado viable seguramente a
mediano plazo lo que podemos ver es que
la cola internacional va a tratar de
solidarizarse de interesarse por el
asunto haitiano sobre todo porque el
asunto haitiano tiene una condición
regional y es la cuestión de la
migración ya lo hemos visto un poco en
algunos titulares también de prensa
sobre cómo este problema se ha afrontado
por los eeuu de una manera pues
verdaderamente caótica y también de
alguna forma ilegítima al no dejar
entrar digamos a los haitianos debido a
su condición de migrantes y eso digamos
que al final de cuentas va a tener que
redundar un poco en medidas extremas es
decir si no se logran soluciones prontas
pues seguramente vamos a tener
soluciones que van a ser extraordinarias
y algo para culminar es que seguramente
a mediano plazo tampoco vayan a ver
elecciones no se pueden celebrar
elecciones en un país que al final de
cuentas tenga la conflictividad social
gigante prácticamente que las elecciones
van a ser es colocarle más gasolina al
fuego y sobre todo van a impulsar mucho
más a las pandillas para hacer esos
movilizados electorales de luz por
rápidamente paralelas palabras a bien
puede el primer ministro aplazar las
elecciones porque podrá pensar que no
hay condiciones de seguridad para
hacerlo con las pandillas en este
momento como están ya lo hice darse en
el poder ya lo hizo y va a ser una
apuesta muy riesgosa porque digamos hay
una opinión una percepción de que las
elecciones son una solución pero no
celebrar las también implica un problema
claro y saben su conclusión de lo que
pueda suceder hay en haití muy
rápidamente en primer lugar no no puede
haber elecciones en este momento en el
país yo creo que todos los tres por lo
menos este coincidimos en ello no puede
haber elecciones porque no hay electores
no no hay estructuras
siquiera hablando de la gobernabilidad
no hay no hay tarjeta electoral no hay
no hay qué sé yo las elecciones todos
coincidimos incluso sé
los eeuu en que en este momento no es
posible que va a pasar a corto plazo a
corto plazo los haitianos desde el país
por lo menos lo que sentimos es que esas
negociaciones que tienen que tener lugar
entre la propuesta de la sociedad civil
y el actual gobierno se va a tener que
acelerarse sea porque hay dos peligros
uno es la intervención y nadie quiere la
intervención
a menos que haya fuerzas ocultos pero
así explícitamente nadie quiere la
intervención y por otro por otro lado
todo el mundo bueno los haitianos tienen
que decidirlo su destino entonces hay
que dejar que se desarrolle ese diálogo
para que podamos llegar a evitar la
intervención félix abel tenemos a la
puerta es una intervención externa bueno
a mis invitados muchas gracias por
habernos acompañado hoy a ustedes
gracias por la sintonía y puede seguir
dejando sus comentarios en las redes
sociales
[Música]